heute mein gast im dialog die
menschenrechtsaktivistin und
islamkritikerin die sich sabatina james
nennt herzlich willkommen
sabatina james ist nicht ihr wirklicher
name warum kennen wir den richtigen
namen nicht
zunächst einmal weil ich ihn opferschutz
programm der polizei kam
als ich von meiner familie mit dem tod
bedroht wurde weil ich den islam verließ
und heute weil ich islamkritische
aufklärung machen und dafür von
islamisten bedroht werde
wir haben vor viereinhalb jahren schon
mal miteinander gesprochen auch in
berlin wie ist es ihnen in den letzten
viereinhalb jahren gegangen hat sich
etwas verändert
ja also die drohungen hinter zuge kommen
und ich kann mich mittlerweile in
deutschland noch weniger frei bewegen
wie damals und das finde ich sehr schade
weil ich bin nach deutschland geflüchtet
um hier meine menschenrechte aus frau
wahrzunehmen und ich stelle fest dass
das hier auch nicht mehr geht weil
unsere regierung auch die täter
willkommen heißt also diejenigen die
menschen die mich bedrohen sie dürfen
weiterhin hier bleiben den geschieht ja
nicht und deswegen ist meiner meinung
nach auch die freie meinungsäußerung
über den islam in deutschland nicht mehr
gewährleistet dann sind sie sehr
profiliert mittlerweile als
islamkritikerin also als clip kritikerin
einer glaubensgemeinschaft sie haben
dazu bücher verfasste man kennt sie aus
zahlreichen fernsehsendungen ist da
nicht die gefahr dass die eigene opfer
geschichte auch den blick auf eine
religionsgemeinschaft in dem fall den
islam verstellt ich finde dass es
überhaupt kein argument
und vor allem empfinde ich das sogar als
hetze gegen die opfer also man muss sich
mal vorstellen
dann würde einem opfer das unter den
nazis gelitten hat sagen es hätte
einfach schlechte erfahrungen gemacht
sie haben ein buch vorgelegt und warnen
vor einer scharia in deutschland also
vor der islamisierung aber die mehrheit
der muslime die hier im land leben sind
ja durchaus friedlich und haben sich
hier ganz überwiegend gut eingegliedert
in die gesellschaft zunächst mal muss
man sagen dass der mehrheits islam der
islamischen staaten gemeinschaft nicht
friedlich ist sondern islamistisch die
islamische staaten gemeinschaft wo ece
hat eine eigene menschenrechtserklärung
herausgegeben die sogenannte kairo
menschenrechtserklärung und diese
menschenrechtserklärung sagt ganz klar
dass frauen und nie und nichtmuslime
niemals rechtlich gleichwertig sein
dürfen
und schon im artikel 1 beginnt das dass
zum beispiel alle menschenwürde haben
aber dass der rechte glaube an der
islamische glaube die garantie für diese
menschenwürde ist das heißt nur muslime
haben menschenwürde
dann steht da auch noch drinnen zum
beispiel dass alle menschen eine
menschheitsfamilie bilden auch im
artikel 1 aber diese menschheitsfamilie
ist in der unterwerfung allahs das heißt
nur mein muslime bilden die
menschheitsfamilie und so geht das
ständig weiter und das ist
menschenrechte nur unter der scharia
gibt und dass das ist dann mehrheits
islam denn wir zurzeit haben weil das
geben die auch vor die sagen das ganz
offen dass sie den islam repräsentieren
sie sind das sprachrohr für den islam
und das 56 islamischen länder dabei sind
da ist das finde ich ein skandal und
dass da überhaupt nicht darüber
gesprochen wird noch mal zurück zu ihrer
persönlichen geschichte sie haben dann
vor jahren ein
ein verein gegründet sabatina ev mit dem
ziel eben bedrängten gerade jungen
frauen mädchen zu helfen was konkret
machen sie da wir helfen frauen die vor
der zwangsheirat flüchten und frauen die
von wie ich zum christentum konvertieren
oder atheistisch werden und dafür von
von ihrer familie bedroht werden wir
haben eine zuflucht wo wir diese frauen
aufnehmen und dort dürfen sie auch so
lange bleiben bis sie auf eigene füße
stehen einige unserer opfer den dazu
flucht waren sind mittlerweile auch in
berlin haben da einen job gefunden und
wir haben kooperationspartner in
deutschland mit denen wir
zusammenarbeiten weil die fälle so viele
sind dass wir gar nicht alle frauen auch
unterbringen können also wir haben um
die 100 hilferufe und dann pro jahr und
dann helfen wir mittlerweile auch
verfolgten christen in meiner heimat
pakistan und mittlerweile auch in
deutschland wo sie in den asyl heimen
von islamischen asylbewerbern
angegriffen werden
wie viele mädchen und frauen betreuen
sie im schnitt also es sind circa 100
anfragen die wir bekommen
und natürlich nehmen wir nicht alle
arbeiten oder den können sie allen
helfen
naja also jede beratung ist eine hilfe
für das opfer aber nicht jedes opfer
entscheidet sich dann auch zu fliehen
manchmal sind es einfach auch fragen die
sie stellen das sie zuerst einmal
schauen kann ich darauf vertrauen dass
wenn ich von zuhause flüchte eine
sicherheit eine stabilität da ist und
dass das im endeffekt was unsere
sozialarbeiterinnen dann machen ich
mache das weil es zurzeit nicht
persönlich wenn wir haben zwei
sozialarbeiterinnen den der zuflucht
arbeiten und die diese frauen betreuen
in unserer zuflucht gibt es nur fünf
plätze
aber wie gesagt wir haben andere
kooperationspartner aber sie sind das
gesicht dieser dieses vereins dieses
hilfevereins
sind selbst aber in einem opferschutz
programm können sie über das propagieren
dieses vereint und über darüber das
gesicht dieses vereins zu sein der kopf
dieses vereins auch aktiv selbst noch
etwas tun oder ist ihre bewegung zu sehr
eingeschränkt meine bewegung ist sehr
eingeschränkt mittlerweile das war ja in
den letzten jahren nicht so stark so
konnte ich mich auch mit den opfern sehr
leicht treffen aber auch heute ich meine
nach dieser sendung werde ich mich mit
einer jungen frau treffen die von ihrer
familie geflüchtet ist und deren
schwester sich sogar das leben genommen
hat kurz vor einer zwangsheirat dieses
opfer treffe ich dann schon aber es sind
ein sicherheitsvorkehrungen da also ich
der erste kontakt ist immer mit einem
personenschützer und das wird auch heute
so der fall sein
sie sind ja auch vor ihrer eigenen
familie seinerzeit geflohen waren mit
dem tode bedroht weil sie sich einer
zwangsheirat widersetzt haben und weil
sie konvertiert sind hat sich daran
etwas verändert haben sie wieder kontakt
zu ihrer familie
also ich habe meine familie seit über
dreizehn jahre jetzt nicht mehr gesehen
ich möchte aber auch ganz klar betonen
dass meine eltern keine monster sind und
auch meine geschwister sie sind sehr
modern und sie haben sich das alles auch
nicht ausgedacht was sie damals getan
haben sondern sie haben einfach nur die
regel mohammed befolgt und nach der
regel mohammeds müssen menschen wie ich
getötet werden da gibt es in der scharia
auch keine ausnahme außer vielleicht
noch lebenslange haft nach der
politischen schule wie herr kindler dass
mir so schön erklärt hat bei markus lanz
aber das ist für mich auch keine schöne
perspektive und das ist ganz wichtig
weil das macht man natürlich auch gesagt
haben meine eltern hätten den islam
falsch verstanden und so weiter nein
meine eltern eltern waren einfach
konsequent konsequenter als andere
muslime und was sie auch schade finde
ist in dieser ehre und charme kultur in
islam ist dass diejenigen die dann auch
ihre töchter nicht mit gewalt beseitigen
von der von der gemeinschaft
ausgestossen werden das heißt
das auch auf den tätern so ein großer
druck von der gemeinschaft lastet dass
sie zum teil einen sozialen tod erleben
wie ausgestoßene sind weil familien die
keine ehre mehr haben weil die tochter
zum christentum konvertiert mit denen
verkehrt man nicht mit denen macht man
keine geschäfte mit denen heiratet man
nicht und die sind wie aussätzige und
waren dann leiden sehr sehr viele
menschen nicht verteidige ist jetzt
nicht es war falsch was sie getan haben
aber ich möchte einfach auch sagen dass
es nicht so schwarz weiß ist sie sind
täter und ich bin opfer sondern es sind
eigentlich alle opfer dieses systems
aber reden wir da nicht von einer ganz
radikalen sehr kleinen minderheit von
muslimen wenn wir auf das verhalten
jetzt auch ihrer familie gucken also es
gibt in deutschland über 3000 betroffene
von zwangsheirat beziehungsweise solche
auch denn die zwangsheirat droht wir
haben jeden monat eine hinrichtung nach
scharia und weltweit gibt es tausende
frauen dem namen der ehre getötet werden
in meinem heimatland pakistan sind über
80 prozent der frauen opfer von der
gewalt im namen der ehre und das könnte
ich weiter fortsetzen wir haben 60
millionen kinder heiraten zurzeit laut
unicef und die meisten kinder heiraten
finden der islamischen welt statt
jede fünfte minute wird ein christ legen
seinem glauben getötet die meisten davon
in islamischen ländern also die die
zahlen sind sehr sehr hoch und selbst
eines ein einzelner fall wäre
sprechen sie mal von den ns bei den nsu
morden von einzelfällen wegen denen
nichts zu unternehmen ist dann schauen
wir uns die reaktionen an und dann sieht
man auch was dieses argument ist ja nur
ein einzelfall auch wert ist ja
selbstverständlich ist jeder fall einer
zu viel
aber kann man sicher schnell
verständigen dennoch ist ja die frage ob
es daraus abgeleitet einen
generalverdacht gegen hier lebenden
muslime geben kann in europa lebenden
muslime werden gerade gesprochen über
die muslime in anderen ländern in
islamischen ländern aber wir sind ja
hier in europa und da ist die frage ist
es richtig da ebenso ein generalverdacht
gegenüber einer glaubensgemeinschaft
auszusprechen also ich habe ja gar
keinen generalverdacht ausgesprochen
ich habe ja nur über die opfer erzählt
also ich habe ja gar nicht ein
generalverdacht ausgesprochen
das heißt sie würden schon sagen dass
man muslime genauso begegnen kann
muslimen wie jedem anderen bürger und
jedem jeder anderen bürgerinnen in
diesem land auch er selbstverständlich
also ich aber nur das gefühl das habe
ich auch selbst damals erlebt ich war
selber muslimen und in diesem kleinen
dorf ins allensbach dieses europa was
ich damals in österreich kennengelernt
habe das ist zurzeit für mich am
zerbrechen
wir wurden darauf genommen mit einer
großen christlichen nächstenliebe
dieses dorf hatte ein katholisches
selbstverständnis die lehrer vor der
schule begonnen hat mit den schülern
haben zusammen gebetet und für mich war
dass so ein so eine heile gesellschaft
in der ich mich damals als muslimin sehr
gut integrieren konnte ich habe keinen
rassismus erlebt und das was mich das
beeindruckt hat war auch ich dachte
immer als muslimin den menschen da ist
nichts heilig aber den war ihr glaube
sehr heilig und das haben die auch in
einem selbstverständlichste gezeigt aber
das ist am zerfallen was die leute auch
die flüchtlinge denke ich dies hier her
kommen gerade märkten ist so ok genau
das gleiche wie ich glaube ich damals
wahrscheinlich auch gedacht habe den
leuten es nicht eilig ich möchte niemals
zu werden und ich möchte mich niemals in
so einer gesellschaft integrieren weil
einfach denke ich ein großes auch
geistiges war
um in unserer gesellschaft da ist gab es
mal in diesem land einen
bundespräsidenten von dem möglicherweise
nicht so furchtbar viel in erinnerung
bleibt aber von der ms der satz der
islam gehört inzwischen auch zu
deutschland wie stehen sie zu dem satz
also ich finde es zunächst einmal sehr
undifferenziert und die ganze debatte
darum finde ich auch total unsinnig weil
zuerst einmal wenn der islam zu
deutschland gehört muss man sich
natürlich fragen welcher von dem ganzen
strömungen und und dann wenn man sich
dann entschieden hat okay vielleicht
mehrheits islam denn die meisten
praktizieren dann ist es dass
sunnitische islam gut dann gehört aber
auch die scharia zu deutschland und das
kann der präsident aber es eigentlich
nicht gewollt haben also ich finds total
unsinnig
nun ist das ja dann noch mal modifiziert
worden durch den fraktionsvorsitzenden
der union im bundestag volker kauder der
auch in abrede gestellt hat gesagt der
islam gehört nicht zu deutschland aber
die muslime gehören zu deutschland
könnten sich mit dem satz eher
anfreunden
also die muslime die demokratisch sind
und unsere grundrechte und das
grundgesetz akzeptieren und danach leben
gehören zu deutschland diejenigen die
undemokratisch sind die rassistisch sind
die gehöre nicht zu deutschland und
sollten wieder zurückgeschickt werden
haben sie ja auch in ihrem buch zum
ausdruck gebracht dass der islam
zumindest eben einer einer
kritikwürdigen haltung vorschub leistet
wir haben aber in diesem land inzwischen
über vier millionen musliminnen und
muslime wohnen wie sollten wir mit
diesen menschen umgehen die
in dieses land gekommen sind hier
überwiegend auch sich integriert haben
die hier arbeiten die hier leben
wie muss man mit ihnen umgehen wie muss
man ihn oder sollte man ihnen aus ihrer
sicht begegnen also versprechen
natürlich das thema integration an
integration kann nur bei denen gelingen
die integriert werden wollen das ganz
wichtig wer frauen betatscht schwule
klatscht juden bepöbelt und christen
angreift dann müssen wir ganz klar sagen
das ist kein armes schutzbedürftige
opfer das in unser land gehört sondern
das ist mit islamistische täter und er
gehört dorthin geschickt wo er das
gelernt hat wenn wir dieses signal
setzen werden wir irgendwann
demokratische liberale muslime hier
haben weil wir das richtige signal an
die muslime geben dass bei uns nur die
menschen leben dürfen die sich an die
menschenrechte halten und auch in
unserer gesellschaftsordnung
sie haben ja lauter taten jetzt
aufgezählt die auch ohnehin schon unter
strafe stehen ist die deutsche
mehrheitsgesellschaft auch in der
anwendung dieser strafen konsequent
strafen bringen meiner meinung nach
nichts solange mir wenn man zum beispiel
jemanden wegen seiner sexuellen
orientierung oder aus anderen gründen
beleidigt oder gar tätlich angreift dann
ist das ja ein straftatbestand
also müssen wir jetzt ja schon wenn ich
wenn ich den opfern zu hören
denn dann ist mir das wirklich neue weil
wenn man sich anschaut wie wenn zum
beispiel draußen muslimischen jugend ab
ins gas dann gehen sie straffrei wieder
raus und das ist anscheinend wieder
moderner dass auch sonst auf den straßen
zu rufen
und da passiert gar nichts erfolgreich
veröffentlicht seine videos über
steinigungen da passiert gar nichts
bekannter islamist richtung konvertit
also zum islam konvertieren richtig also
ich finde schon dass wir in einer sehr
sehr schlimmen meinungsdiktatur zurzeit
leben ja also war dann dürfte hier
dürfen heutzutage leute wie pierre vogel
ihre propaganda betreiben und da
passiert nichts wenn sie so steinigungen
aufrufen
auf der anderen seite darf ein
journalist kein smiley nach einem
statement dass er vielleicht als spaß
geschrieben hat darunter setzen weil
dann ist die meinungsdiktatur da und
dann wird er von seinem job gekündigt
also ich finde das ist eine sehr perfide
strategie und sehr ungerecht was gerade
abläuft
worauf führen sie das zurück sie
springen gerade vermutlich matthias
matussek an ein journalist der für die
welt gearbeitet hat ich habe öfters
überlegt warum wird der anti
demokratische islamismus nicht
konsequent bekämpft
und ich denke ich meine die islamisten
sind verbündete und geschäftspartnern
erdogan katar saudi arabien die emirate
und vielleicht stehen die
wirtschaftsinteressen vor den
demokratischen willen der gesellschaft
und der bevölkerung und ihren wünschen
anders kann ich mir das ja eigentlich
gar nicht erklären man müsste die leute
selbst fragen man müsste sie selbst
sicher aber glauben sie dass tatsächlich
also die haltung der gesellschaft
geprägt ist von den
wirtschaftsinteressen großer unternehmen
und des staates ich habe nicht die
gesellschaft ich habe gesagt die politik
die gesellschaft hat keinen vertrag mit
soldaten oder im rat denkt also lehnen
das sogar ab aber wenn wir haben unsere
waffentransporte nach nach saudi arabien
und und die und saudi arabien ist
partner der bundesregierung und wir
haben katar und erdogan und so weiter
als als als partner und dann
sind islamisten unsere partner deswegen
die frage
deswegen wird doch nicht eben ein
unabhängiges deutsches gericht darauf
verzichten strafverfolgung anzuwenden
nur weil wirtschaftliche interessen von
großunternehmen oder auch von staaten
betroffen sind
es heißt ihr bild von der deutschen
justiz dass sie diesen vorgaben oder die
solchen vorgaben solche vorgaben
überhaupt gibt
ich habe vorhin von antidemokratischen
islamisten gesprochen
die andere angreifen und die gewalt
lehrern wie pierre vogel und diese leute
die gewalt predigen und die gewalt
ausüben die dürfen weiterhin in
deutschland da bleiben der polizei sind
genügend fälle bekannt aber es passiert
ihnen gar nicht wenn sie möchten kann
ich ihnen gerne ein paar beispiele
bringen
von leuten die andere angegriffen haben
leuten die christliche asylbewerber in
den asyl heimen fast zu tode geprügelt
haben und die wurde islamistischen täter
weiterhin hier bleiben dürfen während
der christ der fast totgeprügelt wurde
wieder zurückgeschickt wurde das kann
ich ihnen erzähle und deswegen wissen
sie ich habe einfach keine illusionen
mehr weil ich einfach den opfern zuhöre
und denen geht es ebenso und für sich
für sie bin ich das sprachrohr
nun gibt es bei vielen menschen in
diesem land auch die befürchtung dass
mit einer großen zahl von flüchtlingen
auch terror oder terrorgefahr zumindest
importiert wird
wie ist da ihre erfahrung sie haben
kontakt zu flüchtlingsheimen zu als
asylbewerberheim ist das tatsächlich
eine eine gefahr die sie sehen als
selbstverständlich kommen mit den
flüchtlingen auch islamisten in unser
land und damit wollen wir eine
rassistische und frauenfeindliche
ideologie in unser land
das haben wir mit köln gesehen das sehen
wir jetzt durch diese neue studie die
über die verfolgung von christen in
deutschen asylbewerberheimen
veröffentlicht worden ist
das für eine studie könnte eine studie
von von christlichen hilfsorganisation
open doors und in dieser studie wird
einfach vorgelegt wie christliche
asylbewerber in den asyl heimen
angegriffen werden
und was für eine verzweiflung da
eigentlich da ist und wie sie vor allem
von deutschen behörden trotzdem nicht im
stich gelassen werden
was bedeutet das denn für die
willkommenskultur die wir ja in diesem
land haben gegenüber menschen die in not
ja auch sich an uns wenden und die hier
zuflucht suchen
zunächst muss ich sagen dass ich das
gefühl habe dass die willkommenskultur
anscheinend nur für diejenigen gilt die
sich lautstark gehör verschaffen und
diejenigen die wirklich opfer sind sehr
oft abgelehnt werden
also ich spreche es einfach auch die die
flüchtlingspolitik von von von der
bundeskanzlerin an
sie spricht von mitgefühl solange aber
die anträge von christlichen
flüchtlingen aus islamischen ländern
regelmäßig und systematisch abgelehnt
werden auf aufnahme in deutschland ist
die behauptung von mitgefühl meiner
meinung nach eine klasse lüge das heißt
es wird sie sagen systematisch abgelehnt
wenn jemand einen christlichen
hintergrund hat also von den fällen und
wie ich vorhin gesagt habe ich kann
ihnen mal ein paar beispiele bringen
wenn sie wollen von leuten die hierher
gekommen sind
ich sage einfach von einem von einem
jungen mann der ist geflüchtet
aus libyen er war dort in der
gefangenschaft von islamischen staat
nach freikauf und einer odyssee über
italien hat es nach deutschland
geschafft hier angekommen wurde er von
islamischen asylbewerbern im asylheim
wegen seines glaubens angegriffen und
die deutschen behörden haben in einer
nacht und nebelaktion ihn und seine
schwester von der familie getrennt haben
ihn zum flug haben sie zum flughafen
gebracht und ich bekam dann den anruf
aus italien
sie haben mich wieder abgeschoben
während derjenige und diejenigen das
waren ja mehrere die
angegriffen haben weiterhin hier bleiben
dürfen das ist es nur ein fall
wir haben die bundesregierung das haben
wir schriftlich vorliegen mehrmals
angefragt für christen die verfolgt
werden in islamischen ländern wo einigen
der familienmitglieder sogar schon tot
sind hingerichtet wurden hier
aufzunehmen
und da hieß es es besteht kein bezug zu
deutschland
und dann frage ich mich natürlich
welcher bezug zu deutschland besteht für
die anderen flüchtlinge die herkommen
haben sie denn grundsätzlich kritik an
der flüchtlingspolitik der der
bundesregierung sowie sie wahrnehmen
ich finde einfach dass diese ganze
flüchtlingskrise auf vielen lügen
aufgebaut ist zum beispiel dass alle auf
deutschland und europa verteilt werden
müssen solange die bundeskanzlerin die
islamische staatengemeinschaft und die
arabische liga nicht einmal angefragt
hat wegen der aufnahme flüchtender
muslime ist die behauptung dass alle auf
deutschland und europa verteilt werden
müssten ja auch eine lüge
und dann kommen die leute hierher und
dann denkt man so ok die diejenigen die
jetzt wir wissen gar nicht ob es unter
den flüchtlingen gewalttäter gibt das
weiß man ja nicht
auch das ist eine lüge denn solange die
politik der polizei nicht einmal den
auftrag erteilt der
verfassungswidrigkeit verdächtige also
bewerber zu zu absolvieren ist die
behauptung dass man das gar nicht wissen
kann nicht richtig
man kann es ja wohl wissen man will es
aber nicht wissen und wenn man ist dann
weiß tut man trotzdem nichts sondern
lässt die verfassungsfeinde hier und das
ist alles was ich kritisiere weil ich
denke da riskieren wir die
menschenrechte und die demokratie und
ist ja gerade diese flüchtlingspolitik
diese willkommenskultur sehr gelobt
worden
nicht zuletzt von den großen kirchen
auch papst franziskus war in die domäne
und hat
dort eben davon gesprochen dass die
flüchtlinge nicht ein kostenfaktor sind
und nicht ein problem darstellen sondern
dass sie ein geschenk sind sie sind
selbst zum katholizismus konvertieren
spricht ihnen da der papst aus dem
herzen
also für mich spricht dann jemand aus
dem herzen wenn die menschenrechte
achtet und ich denke das franziskus ist
wirklich groß meint aber wenn die
kirchen und die großen kirchen die
bischöfe in deutschland bis heute nichts
unternommen haben für ihre
glaubensbrüder die in asyl heimen
angegriffen worden sind
dann muss ich sagen sprechen wir diese
leute überhaupt nicht aus dem herzen
wenn sie solche aussagen von sich geben
wenn das so ist wie erklären sie sich
dass das also ausgerechnet vor den
eigenen gläubigen eben die katholische
kirche oder die kirchen insgesamt die
großen kirchen da so eine haltung an den
tag legen wie sie beschreiben event
papst hat mal gesagt die kirche ist kein
museum für heilige sondern ein
krankenhaus für sünder und ich denke
dass auch manche bischöfe und kardinäle
dem opportunismus erlegen erlegen sind
und das ist ihnen wichtiger ist den
medien und der gesellschaftlichen
gesellschaft eigentlich den medien nicht
zu widersprechen und der kurs der da ist
da nicht entgegen zu zu strömen
weil man dann sonst einfach auch
ablehnung erfährt und darum geht es
eigentlich meiner meinung nach dass sie
sich mehr verpflichtet fühlen den leuten
nach dem mund zu reden als ihre
schäfchen zu beschützen und und ihn und
sie zu besuchen in den asyl heimen und
es ist eine ganz große verzweiflung
dabei den asylanten ich war letztens
erst in einem asylheim baden württemberg
und die die christen sind sehr
verzweifelt weil sie das gefühl haben da
westen
ist komplett taub für ihr ganz
besonderes leid sie werden gerade
vernichtet vom islamischen staat das
orientalische christen dom ist am
aussterben und es kräht kein hahn danach
und sogar ihre eigenen glaubensbrüder
lassen sie liegen und das finde ich sehr
bedenklich und so lange dass unsere
bischöfe und auch der heilige vater
nicht ganz klar angesprochen hat spricht
mir das nicht aus dem herzen
ich bin katholisch aus ganzem herzen und
das hat aber jetzt mehr mit der lehre
der kirche zu tun als über die
politischen meinungen von unseren
geschäften und dem papst da gibt es ja
nun kehrt es vielleicht ganz zum schluss
ist ein etwas düsteres gemälde dass sie
zeichnen auch eben von dem einfluss des
islam
hier aber gibt es bei ihnen denn auch so
einen punkten hoffnung dass so etwas
entstehen könnte was bassam tibi mal den
euro islam genannt hat also einen
einsatzwagen einer form von
zivilisiertem islam der demokratie
kompatibel ist und die menschenrechte
stark beachtet als sie das beschrieben
haben das nächste was ich gesagt das ist
kein düsteres bild von der realität
ich habe von real menschen gesprochen
die leiden kann ja düster sein
ja ja ja aber ich denke es wird einfach
oft gesagt dass man zu sehr kritisiert
und man soll ja auch das positive
schauen und da habe ich das auch erlebt
mal bei einem vortrag das nach dem
vortrag dann von zwangsheiraten
gesprochen dann stand da eine
evangelische pfarrerin auf und hatten
wir dann gefragt ob ich auch was
positives sagen kann
also von leuten wo man sich eigentlich
die solidarität erwartet und ich habe
oft gedacht auch schon in der geschichte
ich wünschte mehr juden hätten ihre
situation negativ gesehen und hätten
daraus maßnahmen gezeigt und auch heute
wenn wir diese dinge so sehen wie sie
sind auch wenn sie düster sind und
daraus konsequenzen ziehen dann kann das
eine positive sache werden wenn ihr
alles positiv sehen und alles verleugnen
dann wird daraus ein richtig negative
sache sabatina james
wir sind am ende des gesprächs ich
bedanke mich herzlich